okay well thank you very much so uh
it's a bit of a math interlude so i'd
like to tell you about these pictures
so spectrahedron
by definition is defined by a linear
matrix inequality so a spectra hidden of
degree n in r to the d
is given by
d plus 1 n by n real symmetric matrices
a0 a1 up to a d we take the alpha linear
combination
and require that this matrix is positive
semi-definite
so what do these objects look like well
for example if n is one if n is one we
have a
one by one
symmetric matrices
then spectrohedral is simply a closed
half space
when n is two
we take two by two symmetric matrices
we get a quadratic cone so for example
in three space they look like this
another very basic observation is the
intersection
of an interfined intersection of
spectrahedra is again a spectrahedron
right because you can stack up
the matrices along the diagonal and take
a bunch of small symmetric matrices and
make bigger symmetric matrices
so finite intersection of spectrohedra
is a spectrahedra so
taking the uh the first statement and
the third statement we learned
that every convex
polyhedron is a spectrahedron a convex
polyhedron by definition is an
intersection finite intersection
of closed half spaces
now convex polyhedra
are of course very very useful because
they are the feasible regions in linear
programming
spectra hedra are the feasible regions
in semi-definite programming
convex polyhedra the mathematics
geometry and combinatorics of convex
polyhedra has been studied for 2000
years
while the
combinatorics and geometry of
spectrahedra
is a relatively unexplored topic
to be
discussed in this lecture
so most of my examples today most of my
pictures will be for d equals three so
most of my spectra hedra will be in
three dimensional space
but i'm going to start out with d equals
two
just to kind of get a sense how these
things look like okay
so semi-definite optimization or
semi-definite programming as i said is
the computational problem of minimizing
a linear function over a spectrahedron
which is the non-abelian version of
linear programming right linear
programming concerns diagonal matrices
so linear programming is semi-definite
programming for diagonal matrices but
here we're doing general symmetric
matrices
so for example if n is 3
then we look at the six-dimensional cone
convex cone of positive semi-definite
three by three matrices that's a
six-dimensional cone
we cut it with a two-dimensional plane
namely the screen plane
and we get this red convex body so this
is a two-dimensional
spectrohedron of degree three
now what can we say about the algebra
and the geometry of this well there's a
polynomial that vanishes on the boundary
that manages on the red boundary
well that's a polynomial of degree three
called the symmetric three by three
determinant restricted
to the screen plane
so this is a plane cubic curve
and it's smooth this is an elliptic
curve
now you might not on the face of it see
the black stuff but that's part of the
real curve so if you take that cubic
polynomial
in the two variables of the screen plane
and you ask mathematica or sage to plot
that curve it will plot
both the red part and the black part
as a warm-up let's solve the
semi-definite program over this
spectrahedon for example go north east
okay
well let's record we don't know how to
do this let's just do this using
calculus
so we're going to record the critical
points so whenever there's a critical
point so we're going to go north east
i'm going to say beep whenever there's a
critical point what beep
beep beep beep
i said beep six times
two red beeps
two black beeps
two complex imaginary beeps you didn't
hear
at the bottom we have the dual picture
duality is very very important in convex
optimization it's equally important
in projective algebraic geometry so
here's the dual picture so we pop open
the second window
and the points in the second window
correspond to the lines in the first
window and the lines down here
correspond to the points up there
so the
sweeping through
corresponds to stabbing this dual curve
with the line so this dual curve here
the red one that's the dual convex body
to
our spectrahedron
and then the black stuff is the rest of
the dual curve so the points on the dual
curve are lines that are tangent
somewhere at the primal curve
so for example as i travel the point
down here
i have a line
travel a line that's tangent somewhere
the sharp corners correspond to the
three special lines of the asymptote
that you see in the primal upstairs
picture so in classical geometry
language here
we have a curve of degree 3
and class 6
down here
of a curve of degree 6
and class 3.
please interrupt me at any time with
questions you know the previous speaker
went way too fast and ended you know
half an hour earlier so
i can go half an hour over time no i
won't
but if you have any questions please
interrupt me okay so this is a
spectrahedron for n equals three and d
equals two
let's up the dimension by one now let's
take our six dimensional ice cream cone
our six dimensional cone of positive
semi-definite matrices and now slice it
with a three-dimensional plane
and then we get this familiar golden
picture
sometimes called the elliptop or the
somosa
statistics this is the set of all three
by three correlation matrices three by
three
positive semi-definite matrices of this
form so i'm plotting in three space all
points with coordinate x y and z
that make this matrix positive
semi-definite
and this is the
the golden picture and you've probably
seen pictures versions of these pictures
somewhere
now this samosa this elliptop has
four special vertices sharp corners out
here
they are the rank 1 matrices
so a general point
in this space
is a rank 3 matrix
if i'm on that surface if i'm on that
cubic surface given by the vanishing of
this three by three determinant then i
by the rank one matrix
but we're really really interested in
low rank solutions so we're going to be
really really interested in the four
sharp corners the vertices they are the
rank one matrices so in this
three-dimensional space
sir
on the surface it's rank two okay so
this uh this for general xyz the matrix
has full rank three and then this
bichromatic surface is the set of all
real points where the rank drops to two
and then there are four special points
where it drops further to one okay
now i'm also drawing the other real
stuff the elephant ears there's a risky
closure so these are all the points x y
and z
where this determinant also vanishes
but where there's one positive
eigenvalue and one negative eigenvalue
so the golden points have two positive
eigenvalues and one negative eigenvalue
the red points have a positive
eigenvalue a negative eigenvalue and a
zero eigenvalue
you said maybe nothing right here is
zero
what are you saying
yes here what did i say plus minus zero
okay thanks nothing okay
that's the picture now here's a question
does every cubic spectrahedron
have these four nodes it looks like
whenever you see these pictures
they're always you know
these four
corners
and the answer is no right that was the
title page right so it turns out
just like in the study of polyhedra that
goes back to 2000 years to people like
you know euclid and so on right you can
study the
combinatorial type of spectrahedra for
example according to the number of nodes
they have
here we see there are two possibilities
right so uh
either we have four nodes we have the
samosa
or we have this little
lemon drop that has a two
nodes and the edge between the two nodes
is actually
contained in the boundary of the
spectrohedron
so either four nodes or two nodes
and one question i like to start to
discuss in this lecture what about
larger degree
for example what about if we don't take
a three by three matrix
what happens if we take a four by four
matrix
now this is a very relevant observation
here so in particular whenever you have
a three-dimensional spectrohedron of
degree three
there's always at least one singular
point there's always a rank one solution
okay so that exists with positive
strictly positive
probability
if you solve your stp on this golden
spectrahedron you'll hit a rank one
matrix which is a desirable thing
um
a couple words about sum of squares of
course many of you are familiar but
you just sort of summarize it in global
optimization suppose we're given a
polynomial f in m real variables x1 up
to xn of even degree 2d
suppose we knew that this is bounded
below and attains its global minimum x
star
we want to compute it right so that's
equivalent to finding the largest lower
bound maximum lambda such that f minus
lambda is non-negative and that's a hard
problem any sense of heart
we can look at the relaxation where we
maximize lambda such that f minus lambda
is a sum of squares of polynomials
and that problem is much easier because
it's a semi-definite program
empirically
it often happens that the optimal value
of the stp agrees with the global
minimum so it is not the case in general
that these two problems are equivalent
because
not every non-negative polynomial is a
sum of squares
but it seems to be the case that
frequently when we run this
we will
be at the optimal point at that optimal
point we're often lucky the dual
solution
often will be a rank one matrix
a rank one matrix looks like this
it's a product of a column vector and a
row vector they are the same vectors and
then looking at that vector we find the
optimal solution x star
suppose my beeping 10 minutes ago didn't
make any sense
because you never took calculus or you
forgot everything that you learned in
calculus so let's solve a calculus
problem without calculus let's find the
global minimum
of a polynomial in one variable of
degree four three x to the fourth plus
four x cubed minus twelve x squared so
that's an instance where m is one and d
is two
okay so we don't know calculus right so
we'll do it using sum of squares so
we're looking at f minus lambda and we
want to
find the largest lambda so that this is
a sum of squares that is to say it's a
quadratic in quadrants it's a definite
quadratics and quadratics so
make my answers i write down a three by
three symmetric matrix with the two
parameters
there's the lambda and then there's one
free parameter mu
multiply with the row and column vector
of all monomials of to at half the
degree
that's a valid identity
and our problem is to find the pair
lambda mu
such that the matrix is positive
semi-definite and lambda is maximum
we take this instance we type it into
matlab and in
0.00001 seconds the answer will come
back
but first this is exactly this picture
right because now we are in the lambda
moo plane
for optimizing
you know the lambda direction so this is
exactly whoops
there's exactly uh
a three by three spectrahedron in two
dimensions mu and lambda
so we're doing exactly an optimization
problem over the red part of my elliptic
curve question
i'm not sure i understood how did you
get mu into the picture
so yes so i wrote down the general so
this is you know so i've given f
and f is a quartic polynomial
and so as a quartic
i can write it as a quadratic in
quadrants
non-uniquely
but this mu exactly captures that
non-uniqueness is that all the non-unity
that's all the non-uniqueness so i i
i'm so it's a quadratic in quadrant so
it's a quadratic in quadratics right so
if i if you give me any polynomial here
of degree
four in one variable so i have five free
coefficients
and then you sort of count parameters
there's exactly the six entries in the
three by three symmetric matrix so
there's one degree of freedom and i
sneak in the move to to get that
excellent question other questions
okay so let's solve it right so the
optimal solution is negative 32 minus
two
you plug back in right so now we're at
the boundary we're at a rank one a red
rank one matrix
so i take this three by three matrix i
fact koleski factor it into a three by
two matrix times its transpose
i can rewrite this
as a sum of squares
and so you see
f
is the sum of two squares plus the
optimal value
so we have a proof a certificate that
negative two is the global minimum
and this as you know as many people in
this audience know
that this works very well for many
polynomial optimization problems
okay
so the talk begins now
so in this talk which will last 45
minutes
i like to do two things
objective one is to show many pictures
i'm an algebraicist
algebraist by definition are the people
who show pictures so that's objective
one objective two
i'd like to tell you about two recent
papers that i was part of
one is called quartex spectrahedra and
there are three co-authors including
cynthia who is here and then there's a
second paper called generic
spectrohedral shadow so i'll take about
20 minutes
per paper
on the pictures here's again the samosa
so that's n equals three
d equals three here's the same picture
just to highlight the nodes the surface
comes out of the nodes
here's the dual convex body it's always
good to draw the dual right so if you
have that red convex body the red
spectra heater and what you do
is you take four quarters
coins that are circular
and you make them touch pairwise
well there's still some holes right and
you fill in the holes
with this
surface that's the quartic steiner
surface and that makes the dual
to this convex body
for this and these are the four planes
these are the planes spanned by the four
quarters
so this picture tells you what's
happening right so if james gives me a
random linear functional that i want to
optimize
well james instance either will be
linear functional that's here on the
round part or it will be linear
functional that's in the quarter in the
circle
if james gives me one that's in the
circle that means that his linear
function is
optimized at a vertex a rank one
solution
but if it gives me a linear functional
that's out here
it will be optimized at a rank two
solution okay so that's the dual convex
part
now ben wrecked in his first talk
actually reduced one of his problems to
semi-definitely spend here so semi-day
high bend so in your talk it reduced one
of your problems to a four by four
semi-definite program so that's what i'm
going to talk about coordinate spectra
here
let's see some examples
so here's an example of a quartic
spectra he'd done in three space
so
i'm gonna write down the stuplets matrix
with ones on the diagonal
and then that's a defines a
three-dimensional spectrahedron
that looks like this
okay
this is quite a special spectrohedron
this is the convex hull of the uh
cosine curve so you look at cosine theta
cosine two theta cosine three theta
also cause an algebraic curve and theta
either runs over all real numbers but
it's enough to go between zero and pi so
the curve sort of goes back and forth it
travels for a while
and it goes back right so as the
parameter it goes back and we take the
convex hull
in the boundary of that convex hull we
have two quadratic surfaces a
red surface and a
turquoise surface and these are simply
the cones
or these two special singular points you
take a the cone over the curve you have
a cubic curve
and you take the cone from the two end
points these are quadratic surfaces
and so algebraically this means that
this determinant the determinant of this
matrix factors into two quadratic
factors so you can make a change of
basis
that replaces this by two two by two
blocks
here's the dual picture here's the dual
convex body
and here you see already an interesting
feature in the dual convex body you have
an edge of this dual convex body that is
not an exposed edge so
and remind you that for convex bodies
there are two notions of face
okay
a face
is a subset with the property that if
two points are in the phase i'm sorry
it's a subset with the following
property if a point lies in and that
point is on the segment between two
other points then these two other points
are also in the subset okay you have to
unravel that that's the definition of
phase
there's also a definition of exposed
face an exposed phase of the convex body
is a subset at which a linear functional
attains its minimum
every exposed face is a face
but not every phase is exposed so here
this edge
is a phase but it's not exposed there's
no linear functional that is minimized
exactly
at that edge
it is a feature of spectra hedra that
every phase is exposed
in a spectrohedron every phase is an
exposed phase
so therefore
spectrohedra the class of spectrohedra
is not closed on the duality right
because
here i have a spectrahedron
every phase is exposed
you have the dual of a spectrohedron it
has a face that's not exposed
here's another spectrahedron the pillow
so
very similar you know
just changing the off-diagonal entry
somewhat
this tetrahedron looks like a kind of
pillow that
many of us sleep on at night
now it has four straight edges
can you come back to the previous
comment but the cone of all uh psd
matrices is self dual
so how
how does this duality break it's because
of the
yeah because
no because here these objects so this so
let me
repeat what nothing said so the cone
of positive semi-definite matrices the
full
six on this case ten dimensional cone is
a self dual cone in 10 dimensional space
but if i take that 10 dimensional cone
and i slice it with the three
dimensional plane
fy i get this picture
this picture i get by projecting so the
the operations of projection and
intersection are dual operations and
they do different things
so we're not
the family of spectrahedra unlike
polyhedra
is not closed on the dueling projection
when you hear this for the first time
that sounds like a flaw right because
we're all so familiar that if we have
polyhedra we cut them we project them we
dualize them we get again polyhedra
that is false for spectrohedra but that
is a feature that is a a good thing
does that answer your question it's a
projection of inspector either it's not
in general a spectro heater so what's
yes so we call these objects
spectrophytal shadows
so spectrum what we'll get to so spectra
here shadow is what you get by iterating
this construction
okay um so here is a quartic
spectrahedron
um
so this matrix actually if you take the
electron is not does not factor right so
it looks like when you draw the picture
it looks like that there are two parts
of the boundary
there's the upper red stuff of the
pillow and the lower green stuff of the
pillow but they are both parts of the
same irreducible quartic curve
the pillow boundary
okay just to make sure the audience is
on the
same page i'm going to pick on a
volunteer rishi
what do you think is the convex dual of
a spectrohead and again a spectrohedron
not necessarily not necessarily right so
exactly so this is the picture this is
actually not a spectra here so now
the dual to the pillow again you would
take it by taking four quarters one for
each
pillow vertex but now you take the core
four quarters and you arrange them you
know
it's a bit hard to see there's a quarter
a quarter quarter you arrange them in a
circle
and then you glue in this dual surface
of degree 12.
but i guess the dual is always a shadow
the dual is always a shadow exactly by
the same argument the dual you can
always get by projecting the psd corner
appropriate slice of the psd code
absolutely
now we're going to use some algebraic
geometry to study these objects
and whenever we apply an applied
algebraic geometry we take a difficult
problem that involves real numbers and
inequalities and we make it easier in
three steps
step one
ignore all inequalities
step two replace the real numbers by the
complex numbers that makes the problem
much
easier step three replace alphine space
by projective space
you're done with that that means any two
circles in the plane meet in four points
when we're done with all of that and
we're down in complex projector space
the problem has become so easy that
maybe even algebraic geometers can say
something about it so we're going to
work in complex projective space p3
with four homogeneous coordinates x y z
and w
by a cemetery i will mean a surface of
degree n
whose defining equation is the
determinant
of a four by four symmetric matrix whose
entries are linear forms and x y z and w
a little proposition if the coefficient
matrices a b c and d so these are real
n by n symmetric matrices if they are
generic random
dense open set
then the singular locus of the surface
consists of n plus one choose three
nodes these are the simplest singularies
these are the little corners
that we saw on the samosa
so for example if n
is two
the blue number is one right those were
my quadratic cones at the beginning
if n is three this number is four right
so a cubic spectrohedron is expected to
have four nodes if n is four this number
is ten
now then this family is a
three-dimensional space
of of summatroids of of symmetric
matrices contains no matrices uh of rank
n minus three or less
and then
the matrices of rank n minus two are
exactly
those notes so if these generosity
conditions hold i'm going to say s is a
transversal symmetry so transversal
because i have my cone of positive
semi-definite matrices say and this is a
plane
cutting with the three-dimensional plane
that is transverse these are the
conditions for transversal
i'm going to use the same language i'm
going to say a three-dimensional spectra
heating is transversal
if it's algebraic boundary the surface
that makes up the colorful boundary is a
transversal symmetry
again for simplicity if i have if you
see some colorful surface in three space
such as
the cylinder back there
to make it simpler we think about the
corresponding complex projective surface
that's an object that's much easier
so the problem therefore is to study the
geometry and combinatorics of the
general case so in this talk i'd like to
talk about the general case transversal
spectra so for example how many of the n
plus one choose three nodes can lie on
the boundary
that problem is interesting for
applications because these are the low
rank solutions paper fine what is the
transversal spectra
so i'm going to say a spectrohedron is
transversal
if the corresponding symmetroid the
corresponding boundary surface
satisfies
these generosity conditions
okay
so we know for cubic spectrohedra that's
the uh either the samosa with four nodes
or the
the uh the gum drop with two nodes
okay so what about the next case
so just so the the one with two nodes is
it also term this or is just yes they're
both transversal
okay so
so here we're taking the six dimensional
cone of positive semi-definite three by
three matrices and they're two types of
random three planes
there's some random three plane that
makes this one
with positive probability maybe 57
percent
and then with complementary probability
maybe 43 percent we get that one
and everything else happens
on a measure zero set
okay those are two types
so does it really make sense to quantify
sure so if you have somebody who can
actually do integrals like peter
then we could we can actually evaluate
these entries so there are two other
nodes that we don't see also there are
two other nodes that are complex exactly
so they're always four complex nodes
that we don't see maybe i should make a
remark so how would an algebraic
geometer draw this picture let me sort
of draw the picture for algebraic
geometers so this is a cubic surface a
general cubic surface is a beautiful
object that has 27 lines on it
and the way an algebraic geometer would
construct it
you would blow up six points in the
plane
so you would take the plane
and you apply a transformation that's
called blow up at six points
now these spectra here are obtained by
six special points that are gotten by
inter by intersecting four lines so if
you take four general lines in the plane
they make six points
right now under this blow up
the lines
become
i'm sorry the four lines they get mapped
to the four vertices on this surface
and the
six points get blown up to the six edges
the six lines
on the spectrahedron okay
now this is defined over the real
numbers right so this is a configuration
the highly reducible curve degree four
with the real numbers and over the
complex numbers there's only one
possibility right over the complex
numbers any four lines
in general position
are equivalent on the projective
transformation to any other four lines
but over the real numbers actually three
types
either
you can have four real lines you have a
configuration like this where each of
the four lines is defined over the real
numbers
that makes this picture
or
you could have
two real lines and one complex conjugate
pair of lines right so two of the lines
are given by a comp that is a real
configuration right if you take it all
together it's defined over the reals
that gives this picture
or you could have four lines that are
two complex conjugate pairs
and that makes the empty spectrum
okay so let's see what happens
for four by four matrices
yes
you said this uh everything else happens
on a set of measure zero yes on this set
of measure zero could you have a
different number of nodes uh you could
have yes you could have up to 16. okay
yes you can have 16 notes
that's the coma surface
okay let's uh so i was very interested
in this question for quartex so i went
around five years ago asking people you
know and we did some experiments so
we've generated random instances so
we've generated you know hundred
thousand four by four matrices and we
counted the number of nodes and it was
always at most eight
okay
there were ten it's easy to make ten but
they were not on the golden
spectrahedron
so i asked this question and then uh
turns out that an answer was given by uh
two real algebraic geometers that trf
and eatenberg and they answered my
question with the following
remarkable theorem
so
there exists a transversal quartic
spectrohedron with beta nodes in the
boundary and sigma real nodes all
together so the complex surface has 10
nodes now those 10 sigma are real and of
those beta are in the boundary of the
spectrohedron
if and only if the following condition
is satisfied so there's some trivial
conditions and some non-trivial ones so
well certainly these numbers are
non-negative because they count things
and certainly sigma is bigger than beta
okay
now sigma is even that's because if you
have 10 solutions and then you travel
through space it'd be 8 6. so the number
of real solutions jumps by 2. okay
the non-trivial fact is that beta the
number of nodes on the spectral unit is
also even
and sigma is at least two so on the
surface on the multi-chromatic surface
there will be at least one real node
whenever you have a non-empty spectre
now this was amazing so they sent me the
paper and i was really really happy they
answered my question it was a 35 page
paper and i didn't understand the word
of the proof okay so it turns out that
the proof is very very indirect it rests
on something called the global tyraeli
theorem for k3 surfaces which i will
spare you the details of
and deep topological results for the
modular space of real k3 surfaces so
these guys had studied this kind of
stuff all their life
and they applied everything they knew
and solved my problem
now i asked them can you actually find
matrices this is possible to actually
construct you know so there are 20
conditions so if you
look at this you know there are 20
possible cases
right so if you look over all
integers beta and sigma that satisfy
these things
the 20 combinatorial types and the
question is can you actually
build spectra and
these are very very non-constructive
techniques so the answer was no so in
this project that i'm reporting about
with cynthia and two norwegians
we give a new direct proof
and in particular um
we give a construction so
let me show you the if direction so the
proof of the f direction
is the list
okay so here's the proof of the f
direction right so so these are
the different combinatorial types so
this is always beta sigma so for example
i'm sorry sigma beta so for example four
comma two means that there are four
nodes on the symmetroid on the real
summatroid two of which are on the
spectroheater
and this is representatives matrices a b
c
okay so there's a list
you can take these matrices type them
into sudumi and see what happens
you say a few words so here's back to
pictures um
i have a question yes do you expect all
of the examples to have integer entries
in the matrices you can make it yeah
because we're in a dense open set so
these are the generic cases so i'm in
the space
of four tuples
of symmetric three by three matrices
that's a forty dimensional
real space
and then
in this four dimensional real space
there's an open set that makes a
non-empty
spectrohedron
and this open set is cut up into 20 open
sets
i'm going to pick
an integer point with small coordinates
and each open set so
making these coordinates small wasn't so
easy
okay but we have a list
okay so here's a picture gallery so for
example here's a spectrometer of type 2
2 okay so this egg
is a spectra and has two nodes and both
of these nodes are on the spectrohenon
so the dark blue
is the spectrahedron and the light blue
is the rest of the symmetry
over here you have an 8 10 specimen so
that all 10 nodes are real
eight of them are on the spectrohedron
two of them are off the spectrum
here's a nice one here's a 0 10. okay
so there are 10 real nodes
on the surface
but 0 are on the spectra here
and this is a projection of this
okay
let me talk a little bit about
projecting these things into the plane
because we're going to get to uh
projections in a moment
but before we do that uh
let me state the the main theorem so
the if direction is proved by making a
list
and the only if direction
is proved using the theorem that goes
back to art arthur cayley
so this is the theorem
the first half of which was proved by
kaley in 1869
and the second half
was in our paper so here's the theorem
suppose we have an irreducible quartic
surface s in three-dimensional space
okay so given by a polynomial degree
four and p is a singular point that's a
note
so we're gonna
place a camera
on that note i'm gonna take a picture
we're gonna project from that node into
the plane
okay
and the following two conditions are
equivalent so this is kaylee's thing
condition one s is asymmetric summatroid
on p corresponds to a rank two matrix
okay so that means the surface has a
representation by a symmetric matrix of
linear forms and the special point p is
a rank 2 matrix in that
4 by 4 matrix
condition 2 is the projection from that
node into the plane
has a branch locus that consists of two
cubic curves c1 and c2
that are totally tangent i'll explain
that that are totally tangent to a
common conic
here's the picture okay so
so here you can see in green there's a
cubic curve
in red there's another cubic curve
and then
in dark blue you have the projection of
the spectrahedron
and then in light blue you have the
projection of the rest of the surface so
here's the uh the summatroid with the
spectrahedron
and it looks like this
and then in addition there is a circle
there's a conic
which is basically
the neighborhood of the camera right so
the camera
sits on the surface
and it sees
a little circle
that's the circle
this is a node that's off the spectrum
in this example
i took a node
so this was a 6 4 type
the four black nodes on the
spectrohedron there are two nodes
outside the spectrohedron maybe where
kaia sits
and then she takes a picture and
that's the picture
and in the circle you know it's the
circle around her camera and it's
totally tangent totally tangent means
that the cubic curve
meets the conic and three double points
so in general if a cubic meets a conic
in the plane they will meet in six
points but here they meet in three
double points so this was known to
kaylee
the new addition is what happens over
the real number so over the real numbers
the pair p comma s is a real pair
meaning the surface is defined over the
real numbers and the point has real
coordinates
if and only if
the reducible curve degree 6 c1 union c2
together
with the conic is a real pair
and there are two cases
either the two cubic curves c1 and c2
are both real
as in this picture
then p is not on the spectral heater
it's maybe in chi is position
position comes the possibility too p is
on the spectrohedron in this case the
two cubic curves are complex conjugate
pair okay
so this characterizes geometrically what
happens as you project the summatroid
together
with the spectrohedron into the plane
and this is used to prove the only if
direction
use the same picture again so
quadratic spectrohedron a projection
from the outside node
and you can see the characteristic
feature is
that the projection ramifies
along two cubic curves each of which is
totally tangent
to the circle
that's the view from the camera
okay
let me wrap up this part of the
discussion
by looking at an example with beta
equals zero
and sigma equals ten so let's take this
four by four symmetric matrix
and maybe we de-homogenize by replacing
w by one minus x minus y minus z
and that's
the picture
now the question for the audience is
what will semi-definite programming do
for this instance so jim takes this
matrix and gives it to an r student at
cornell
and that our student picks random linear
functionals 10 000 times
and looks at the optimal matrix and
sidumi
what's the rank of that optimal four by
four matrix
question clear so i take this matrix
i replace w by one minus x minus y minus
z
i pick a random linear function on x y
and z and i minimize subject to this
being
positive semi-definite i get an optimal
4 by 4 matrix
of rank two
right
because there is no rank one point on
this dark blue spectral heap
i'm sorry rank three
this is a four by four matrix i get a
rank three
every point every blue point has rank
four three
the only rank two points are the black
points but they're away from the
spectrahedron so this example shows that
unlike in the cubic case you know we
cannot there are instances where the
ring cannot may not drop by two
all the optimal solutions are smooth
points
okay so this was the second part
of the talk so i talked about quartic
spectrahedron so this was intended
as a beginning of an exploration of the
combinatorial types of spectrahedra
so you mentioned that this theorem
was proved using all this heavy
machinery
but
did you explain how you came up with
these constructions or and and whether
you have now an alternative proof of
that's the only proof yes there are two
proofs so this there's the theorem so
this is the theorem
and there are two proofs
and this is very very very heavy
machinery
and this is a
much easier 19th century
so we have a new proof that's based
on the projections into the so this
parity condition on beta and sigma comes
out of this state that is correct so
that comes out of the proof so if you
analyze very carefully
what happens here
then you get the parity condition and
you get the lower bound on unsafe this
gives you a systematic way of
constructing and it gives you also well
yes so this also you you know you draw
it sounds easy but it's a little tricky
right so all you need to do is you know
to draw circles in the plane
and cubic curves that are green and red
that touch like this
and you have a certain amount of control
doing that
and then you
go back so you
so basically control this
three-dimensional body
by controlling this two-dimensional
picture
cynthia is smiling because it wasn't
quite so easy but it's certainly easier
than the other proof
okay new topic
so kanjin you can reboot
new topic you know forget everything i
said
in the last 20 minutes
like to talk about what some people call
extended formulations or lifts
a semi-definite program
so we define a spectrohedral shadow
to be a projection of a spectrohedron or
algebraically
a spectrohedral shadow is a subset of d
dimensional space vectors x1 up to xd
such that they exist some other vector
y1 up to yp
such that
a linear combination of matrices a i d
of them
and b j p of them plus a constant c is
positive semi-def so i'm specifying a
spectra here on upstairs in d plus p
dimensional space
and then i eliminate the y variables i
project into the space with the x
coordinates
now of course if there are no y
variables that's exactly spectrahedra
right so there's no existential
quantifier these are exactly the
spectrahedra that we discussed
and these are intersections of the cone
of positive semi-definite matrices with
an alpha in linear space
so spectrohydral shadows are projections
of spectra
now there's sort of one big conjecture
in in convex algebraic geometry namely
that every closed convex semi-algebraic
subset of d space is a spectrometer
shadow so
every
convex
optimization problem and this family has
a extended lmi representation
but the bad news is that even if this
true is the dimension of the lift that
you have to go to is very very high
dimension
is there any way to explain this briefly
the motivation for the conjecture why
are you expecting to be true
uh
i'm not sure i expect it to be true
it's been proven in many cases so so
there is a systematic way of
constructing uh so using the laser sos
construction
you can get approximations
and then if you're lucky you know many
of these approximations and the limit
will be exact and that's one way so one
way to construct these lifts is to run
some kind of a hierarchy question given
that we know simple examples where these
hierarchies
don't converge in a finite number of
steps
then
you know
in
like
why why is the conjecture reasonable in
that case i don't think it's reasonable
it's proof and i mentioned too it's not
and it's proven they're not singular
it's proved in many cases
in the non-singular case so many people
such as daniel and pablo and
many people think that this is a very
interesting and important conjecture and
it's been proven in many cases
i'm not saying that i find it
interesting but many people find them
so i'm going to be interested in generic
case i'm going to do something that we
always do in algebraic geometry i'm
going to look at the data that are
generic so let me assume a i b j c a
random symmetric three by three matrix n
by n matrices so there's some crazy
discriminant in the 40 dimensional space
of
matrix tuples i'm going to pick an
instance outside that space okay
now that's a very unreasonable thing to
do in this audience because all sdps and
sos instances you will ever see
will be very very special okay so every
particular stp problem that's ever been
studied at the university of waterloo
will lie on that discriminantal
hyperservice but i'm gonna
analyze the random case first the
generic case
okay so i just said
that 20 types
for example if n is four d is three and
p is zero
so the first thing we might ask let me
take one of these blue things and
project it into the plane so what do you
get by projecting from r3 into r2 okay
so what is the degree and number of
singularities for the boundary curve of
a generic spectrohedral shadow
and again the parameters n is the size
of the matrix these are four by four
matrices
d
is the image dimension that's the number
of x variables
and p is the number of y variables that
i eliminate that's the co-dimension of
the projection
say this again we have upstairs a p plus
d dimensional space
we write down the n by n matrix
we eliminate p variables and we're
projecting into a d dimensional space
i want to ask the question what happens
so this is a question i find more
interesting namely suppose i have a
convex
semi-algebraic closed basic what i was
said in the plane we know by a theorem
of shadow it has a lift by laser
construction it can be lifted into some
dimension
but i'm interested in can it be lifted
into dimension three
given the curve in the plane does it
come from three space well the
obstructions are quite serious let me
hint at that so here's what happens if n
is four d is two and p is one
well the algebraic boundary of the
spectrohedral shadow will be a curve of
degree 12.
well because
i have a quartic surface
the ramification locus is given by
taking a derivative so the derivative of
a polynomial of degree four
has degree three
four times three is twelve so by bizu's
theorem the ramification curve is a
curve degree twelve
this degree twelve curve is very very
very singular it has 46 singular points
10 of these singular points are the
images of the nodes so here's a specimen
where we have 10
blue nodes on the spectrahedron and
their images in the plane or singular
points on the curve so
so for example this singular point
is a singular point of the complex curve
that's isolated in the real plane
it's clear it's like x squared plus y
squared equals zero right so x squared
plus y squared equals zero
defines a curve
with an isolated point and
that's such a singular point but in
addition to those ten blue singular
points that come from the projection
there are 36 red points
that come from just by projecting right
if you have a curve in three space that
you get by intersecting a cubic surface
and a aquatic surface
and you project into the plane by the
degree
genus formula that
we often ask our students in the
qualifying exam in the math department
there will be 36 red singular points in
the plane so the upshot is they're
serious obstructions so even if you see
this nice
convex body
in the plane that looks you know not too
bad right
it has a very very high degree of
singularity in the complex curve in
order to be liftable into three spins
so here's the questions i like to
address in the remaining
10 minutes maybe i will not go over time
too long
so let's look at a generic spectrohedral
shadow of type ndp n is the size of the
matrix d
for downstairs the downstairs dimension
and p for projection is the co-dimension
of the map
so here's an example okay so this convex
hull of this red curve that's an example
of a spectrohedral shadow in the plane
that we will
analyze in a moment
so the three questions i like to address
and answer is what ranks do you see in
the boundaries so the upstairs matrices
they have some rank these are going to
be n by n matrices of some rank
and then what are the possible ranks
that you see in the boundary
how many irreducible components are
there in the boundary hypersurface and
what are the degrees of those
hypersurfaces those are the questions
i would like to answer
okay so
let's take this example so
so here's a spectrohedral shadow of type
3 2 2. so 3 is the size of the matrix
there are two x variables
and there are two y variables that i
eliminate okay so this is this formula
describes a four-dimensional
spectrohedron of degree three
i'm projecting it into the plane and i
get
this
shaded picture
and the algebraic boundary consists of
two
curves of degree four
there's one curve that's the red curve
this cardioid curve
and that's given by
this polynomial and the pre-image is
upstairs the general pre-images will
have rank one
so the rank one part
of the exposed boundary upstairs
gets mapped
to the red part of the boundary
okay that's an irreducible curve degree
four
there's also four lines in the plane
that form an irreducible curve over q
okay
and that's the other part so if you look
at the rank two locus so if you take the
three by three determinant
and you
project it down it ramifies along four
lines
and those are the four lines that you
see in this particular choice only three
contribute to the actual boundary of the
spectro hero chef
so i like to ask the question what
happens in general so this is an example
this is the behavior
that you see for p equals two d equals
two and n equals three
what can we say about these polynomials
in general
well here's the answer
so there's something called the
algebraic degree of semi-definite
programming that was studied
together with knee and rana start and
then further developed an exact formula
was given by von bortmann ramstad
and
i'm not going to define that but i'm
going to sort of define it implicitly so
let s be a generic
spectrohedral shadow of this type ndp
and the theorem says that the rank of a
general point of the boundary
will be in some range there will be an
upper bound
in terms of n and p
and a lower bound in terms of n p
independent of d
that's sometimes called the pataki range
now if you look at all the points of
rank r they form an irreducible
component in the algebraic boundary of
our shadow
and that algebraic boundary is an
irreducible hypersurface whose degree is
independent of d
and it's equal to this number delta of p
plus one n comma r
okay
now
if d is one
let's take a breath okay
if d is one so if we have this high
dimensional spectral heat and we're
projecting onto the line
that's semi-definite program
right so projection onto the line the
two end points right that's maximize and
minimize
so so for d equals one and that's the
definition of algebraic degree of
semi-definite programming so
sort of the new part of this theorem is
that this is independent of d
and rather than
even attempting to give you a formula
i'm going to give you a table and in
color you have the two examples we saw
so far
in
the columns
is the size of the matrix so this is the
column for eight by eight matrices
the rows three four five that's p that's
the co dimension of the projection
r
is the rank that you see in the pataki
range
so for example here where at the bottom
there are four possible ranks so what
we're saying is
if you take a 10 by 10
matrix you specify a spectrogram
upstairs
and you map it down
the core dimension 9 projection
then in the boundary you're going to see
expect to see
matrices of degree 9 8 7 and 6 and these
are the degrees of the polynomials that
cut out those red boundaries again right
there yes if you when you do p equals n
minus one that's time
if you do d equals one
so if we're projecting so if the shadow
is just a line segment i see this is
independent exactly it's independent of
d so the punch line
so it's independent of d so these are
the two examples we saw so for example
if p is 1 n is 4 and the rank is 3
that was our curve with 46 singular
points in the plane
and then this was the cardioid example
that was p equals 2 and n equals
um almost done right so
only three slides
so here's an example um
so
i'd like to end by talking a little bit
about the degeneration
aspect so let's do an example with four
two one
again
n is four that means we have a four by
four matrix
and then
d is two so the shadow is in the plane
and p is 1 there's one y coordinate
so this is a projection from 3 space
into the plane
now that's exactly our curve degree 12
okay so let me pick epsilon to be 0.02
okay
well then you know i get this degree 12
curve here it is in purple it has 46
singular points
over the complex though
and you can see
the spectrohedral shadow okay
now what we're really interested in what
stephanie really is interested in what's
happening as epsilons goes to zero right
because if epsilon goes to zero then we
have some structured example that we
really care about
so what happens as epsilon goes to zero
this curve of degree 12
becomes a degenerate curve of degree 12
consisting of six double lines
namely the six lines spanned
by the four vertices of a regular square
this is a representation this is
a lifted extended representation of the
regular square okay
there it is now what are these two red
lines doing well they appear
algebraically
but they appear to about each of these
lines has multiplicity two
so as they take the epsilon and make it
positive they sort of disappear
like a double root can disappear so it
disappears
so this is i think what's important to
understand so
the second to last slide is titled pablo
students from mit hamza and james
have a wonderful new paper where they
succeed in representing the
k-gon the regular k-gon for various
values of k
and this is an example we took from then
so this is the representation
of the regular hexagon
extended formulation for the regular
hexagon so
this is our shadow
so here n is four d is two p is three so
there's a five dimensional spectrahedron
and then this five dimensional
spectrohedon represents
the regular hexagon
algebraically what's going on well you
look in the table all right so
p is three
n is four so there are two possible
ranks so the rank
can be three or two
on rank three we're expecting an
irreducible occur of degree eight
on rank 2 we're expecting an irreducible
curve of degree 30.
and we can see
a shadow of that complexity in this
diagram so if we take the six
vertices and we draw all the lines
we actually see
a curve of degree 30 so let me try this
so
6 choose 2
is that 15.
okay now i forgot got ahead of myself so
anyway so
is an irreducible curve degree 30 that
degenerates to this
so i think what's happening we have the
so i think with this 15 exactly so
that's 15 and it's actually each has
multiplicity 2. so it's this curve you
know he generated degenerates to this
pitch
so with minus three minutes left let me
end so the conclusion of the second
paper is that we do now understand the
generic case
so if we have
random matrices a i b j and c
we understand exactly the polynomials
downstairs and x one up to x d
that describe the boundaries of a
spectrohead or shadow
be very very interesting of course now
lots of work is needed to look at
specific situations so if these matrices
a i b j and c are
not generic but maybe they represent a
particular hierarchy or they represent a
particular family of combinatorial
optimization problems
how does this generic situation
specialize as epsilon goes to zero
thanks for your attention
so
i assume in this table you don't list
possible degenerate cases in case
as a new you said you have a set of
matrices but there
but some the combinatorial type is only
achieved in measure zero that's correct
this is what happens with probability
one so if you pick up matrices a i b j
and c
randomly with and then with probability
one this is what you will observe
but for your previous paper you
understood all the possible scenarios
in this case yeah exactly it's a very
very tiny case you know for four by four
matrices in dimension three
there we understand everything that
happens so there's that's the first so
here the that's the first case where we
can actually describe quote unquote the
combinatorial types of spectral heat so
there we understand all types
um but still the degenerations are still
interesting so i should maybe say
there's still interest you know
for example this one is not generic
right so this is not generic in the
sense there's an entire curve worth of
singular points so that we haven't
worked out yet but in principle
we could do it in in that case
can you say something i mean in your
table
uh
are there ways of computing those
like asymptotics of those numbers with
integral geometry or something i mean
yes
so
there is a formula well the formulas
there's a formula so yes you could study
the asymptotics
somehow these are supposed to be like
the
geometric
an integral meaning or
uh
yes so these are certain intersection
numbers so there's a technique called
schubert calculus that gives these
numbers
perhaps more interesting there there's
another question you can ask that's
perhaps even more interesting and again
people and this former student have made
a contribution
you can ask what's the probability that
these cases will be attained
right so we're saying
if you pick a random you know
10 by 10 matrix you know in this many
dimensions
every optimal matrix will have rank nine
eight seven or six
and there's an integral that you can try
to evaluate that tells you what the
probability distribution is on that case
and that's very very interesting so
there's an integral geometry formula
that gives you information
what we compute this is the same as you
did
i think
so it's been again